y 14 días después del derrumbe la
'operación rescate' llega a su fin a
partir de las 12 de la noche de este
miércoles la misión pasó a ser una de
solo recuperación
así lo informó daniela levin cava la
alcaldesa del condado de miami dade
con profunda tristeza les comparto que
tomamos la extremadamente difícil
decisión de hacer la transición de la
operación de búsqueda y rescate a la
operación de recuperación
sí
gracias a los esfuerzos de hasta 200
rescatistas 18 restos humanos más fueron
hallados en los escombros del edificio
el miércoles hasta el momento el saldo
del derrumbe es de 54 víctimas mortales
y 86 desaparecidos y aunque se han
utilizado todas las estrategias posibles
y todas las tecnologías disponibles las
autoridades consideran que existen cero
posibilidades de encontrar
sobrevivientes pero algunos mantienen la
fe
el anuncio de hoy llega como resultado
de un consenso entre los más cercanos de
los esfuerzos de rescate de que la
posibilidad de que alguien todavía esté
vivo es casi nula probablemente tengan
razón pero al final dios todavía está a
cargo y aunque parece que no hay
posibilidad de encontrar vida entre los
escombros todavía es posible un milagro
este paso
aún se desconocen los motivos que
llevaron al repentino colapso parcial de
sampling towers out pero un informe de
ingeniería que data de 2018 advertía ya
de graves daños estructurales el resto
de la edificación fue demolida de manera
controlada para dar mejor acceso a las
ruinas y ante el temor de los posibles
estragos de la tormenta tropical elsa el
compromiso ahora está en identificar a
las víctimas y ayudar a los familiares
de los fallecidos a darle un cierre a la
tragedia